good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and
happy Friday Friday gotta get down on
Friday everybody's looking forward to
the weekend week Friday Friday Jack and
cl on
Friday hey Jack hey CL how you doing
today such a treat because you were
supposed to be lock tur in LA but you
came home a day early which meant that
we could get back to business as usual
here in our remote podcasting setup so
hi hi yes what a nice treat that we
ended up this week was very fluid up in
the air and then we ended up starting
the week together and ending the week
together we had great episodes in
between but I'm sorry there's nothing
like Jackson cler remote setup I have to
say that is definitely my favorite way
to podcast I prefer it to podcasting in
person really you prefer it to when I'm
in New York or you're in flamingos yes
wow hot take actually I wonder why I
have a hot take okay what's your take I
like don't like I hate podcasting in
flamingos like I feel like I do my worst
work there and I always look ugly I feel
like we always have a really fun episode
because we have so many things to share
because we've been doing like fun things
down here same with when I'm in New York
but like we lead our own lives there so
it's like when you're here like you're
living with me we just have like so many
funny stories like staying up late night
chitchat watching stuff together but the
next time you maybe come to New York you
might be staying at my house too that's
true so we might have that same energy
that you don't like
apparently actually yeah maybe don't
stay with me no I um I feel like I
haven't even spoken about how I'm
literally moving in like 5 days that
that's how I like to move in this world
like you know do things in the dark and
they'll show in the light like you don't
need to tell everyone every step that
you're taking but then bam I'm in a new
house what's good counts
bam a [__] bullet rips rips off pot
of your head your brains are laying on
the ground in little bloody pieces now I
ask you would you give a [__] what kind
of pants a son of a [__] you shot you
was wearing let's talk about that sure I
mean best movie ever my cousin Vinnie if
you haven't seen it finish watching the
toast finish watching the toast because
that's what you need to do today we need
your download and then go watch my
cousin Vinnie it's probably one of the
greatest monologues in cinemat
history and I'll of course recreate it
but then I do have a story for you okay
imagine your AA so here let me should we
just set it up because yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah what's her name in real life
Marissa to Marissa to she's dating
Vinnie Vin my cousin he's a lawyer and
he's going hunting with the legal team
down in wherever the [__] they are
trying to get his cousin off of a murder
case and he's trying to pick out his
pants for the hunt so he's asked and
Marissa to at this point is just had
enough with v yeah they're like living
in a motel like they're from the north
they're like in the South in the sticks
she's not for this life so he's like
what do you think of my pants and she's
just done and she storms out of the
bathroom and she says imagine your idea
you prance in along you get a little
thirsty you spot a little Brook you put
your little dear lips down to the cool
clear water and Bam a [__] bullet
rips off part of your head your brains
are laying on the ground in little blood
pieces now I ask you would you give a
[__] what kind of pants the son of a
[__] who shot you was
wearing scene
ends now I want to say like for many and
this is something like I've it's time to
be honest you know MH this is a
monologue I have memorized and recited
many times at one point like I
definitely made it part of my
personality and I just want to say I
have a very distinct memory of us as a
family watching that movie and becoming
obsessed with that monologue and like it
was your thing Claudia I like I
literally stole it from you and I'm like
I know the monologue like I made it my
thing I I I know that I did that and I'm
sorry and like it's my that so nice cuz
I would never have said it because I
would sound [__] crazy like you would
you
would if I said like the monologue was
mine I really identified with it and I
plucked it out from the movie and like
it really resonated with me you did and
I stole it and I'm like I know the
monologue like I made it my like I made
for I feel like for a while on like my
Snapchat back in the day I used to like
do it all the time yeah but I also feel
like I can recognize that like you did
it better than me so like you take it
and you run with it I feel like that
happens a lot of times on the show it's
like I'll have like an idea or a thought
that like I sort of whisper and then you
give it like a megaphone and you know
that's why we're such a great team it it
takes both you're the Creator and I'm
the thief no I'm the Creator but you're
the megaphone okay yeah I just wanted to
like I wanted mostly to let the audience
but more so you know like I'm aware of
right now okay that's good that's good I
thought maybe you wouldn't know what I
was talking about but like I have a
vivid memory of like it was like you
were obsessed with it and I stole it
right no I've like suppressed that over
the years because it's just like it it
was no long and it was just like no
longer mine and and trying to like make
like I would just sound [__] crazy
like like it's mine so I just had to let
it go I had to let it go I would never
have said that on the show because I
would have sounded nuts yeah no like you
can't steal a monologue like I invented
the monologue you did in family thank
you yeah welcome this means a lot wow
I'm so glad that you knew what I was
talking about but also like I can
recognize you do it better you have the
more like theatrical personality I also
just can't imagine you like with the
sharp [__] you know like yeah yeah you
have to say do it do it no no no no not
yeah yeah yeah yeah come on come on come
on come on I um I I I mouthed it when
you were doing it so people like got the
gist Jackie come on like give us your
best Oscar winning performance but you
you know I'm not an actress this is why
this isn't for me like that's why I was
happy to let you take it really Claudia
for sure but you deserve your shiny
moment with the monologue that you wrote
so you no I just we can all recognize do
it that it's just not going to be great
no it's going to be amazing what are you
talking about come on no no I'm shy come
on no no no it's okay it's yours it's
your thing I don't want to no but it's
your thing like come on it's okay the
audience doesn't want to hear it again
guys drop a a comment there anything
like more annoying and upsetting than
someone like putting you on the spot to
do something that you really don't want
to do yes I'll tell you what it is
putting someone on the spot and they
won't do it like on yesterday's episode
Heather McDonald was talking about how
she loves to sing and I didn't know that
about her and I'm like sing something
for us and I thought she was going to
like be like no she didn't miss a
[__] beat she started singing
immediately and she has an amazing voice
wow yeah I didn't know that about her
you know what I'm noticing a trend I
have a theory that's coming to me I feel
like a lot by the way I know exactly
what you're going to say and I know
exactly who made you think this no it's
you and now saying Heather McDonald
because I was going to say I feel like a
lot of podcasters and creators like have
actually a really nice voice and I think
the person you're talking about is also
Remy yes like a lot of influencers
creators podcasters have a nice voice
and I feel like maybe they entered into
like public life because like becoming a
pop star wasn't happening for them so
it's like they had this voice their
whole life that they thought maybe would
make them a star and you know it took
them nowhere so they've tried a
different Avenue and have achieved Fame
in that way but it's not a coincidence
that all of those people have a nice
voice because they grew up like always
being the star of the show okay I Remy
was a person I thought also but I also
recently saw a Tik to where Alex Cooper
was singing and she had a good voice I'm
telling
you my I think okay your theory is good
too but I also think there's an
alternate side of the theory where it's
like maybe just having like a decent
voice is super common
what do you how do you explain me no
like you're one of the outliers I'm
saying like maybe having a good voice is
the exception isn't the exception maybe
you're the exception I would love to see
percentages how many people like you
know polls let's do a poll how many
people have like an amazing voice how
many people have like a lovely voice can
carry a tune and how many people have a
bad voice like me right it's so crazy to
me that like you can't even like sing a
song I know it's so sad cuz I'm such a
musical person of course and I imagine
when you have children like so much of
their early years yes are revolved
around music I do think that some of the
children's like lullabi songs are really
easy to I think I sound nice obviously
you guys heard when I sang can't help
falling in love that was a classic
jackieo hit but like you are my sunshine
it's like just a couple notes I don't
think you can really [__] it up even me
now I hate to be like such a nitpicker
and like a control freak but you know
that the aesthetic of this show is my
pride and joy and your mic flag is
upside
down
La I switched over my studio this
morning I know I know I can't I'm not
angry thank you so much I feel better
but I just feel like one we should clip
something from the beginning of the show
so the upside down mic flag goes viral
engagement I'm thinking the Marissa to
moment for a clip yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah and also do you know that the cons
theory about Marissa to and the Oscars
run it by me okay let me just look it up
because no
um damn I wish I refill my coffee this
morning do you remember of course
Moonlight you know the whole La La Land
yes yes so she won the Oscar for my
cousin Vinnie and there's this big
conspiracy theory that like the envelope
was wrong not that she didn't deserve it
but if you watch the it appeared like
the envelope was open already and maybe
and and they didn't fix it okay like
they fixed La La Land but they're saying
they say the conspiracy theory that like
with Marissa Chom they just you know
they covered it
up just like a thought okay cool I love
that it literally doesn't matter cuz the
Oscars are ridiculous like okay you won
or you didn't win your life is the same
really so true it's kind of like this
arbitrary thing no it's beyond arbitrary
wait we've been talking for 11 minutes
and we haven't even given our big
announcement of the
day we have so many announcements all
the time it's hard to keep them in check
but this one is so exciting it is you
want to go or you want me to go I don't
know it's you have your hand you have
your hand go go go I have my hand on the
newest Spritz Society F flavor passion
fruit it is so good this one I got to
try before release I tried it last week
and it's so freaking good so I'm going
to I'm going to show you the can it's a
gorgeous
magenta pink purle color like it
compliments the other can so beautifully
but it stands on its own too it's its
own personality we had pulled everyone
asking what they think the next flavor
should be so this is exactly what people
wanted the number one requested flavor
was passion fruit it's so tasty if it
wasn't so early I would crack One open
but maybe like tonight a little Shabbat
passion fruit little ASMR tropical like
you feel like you're on vacation it's
Island Vibes it's so good people are
saying it's our best flavor yet and
that's what's so exciting every time we
were they said that about pink lemonade
they said that about peach pink Lem oh
Peach right it's like we keep topping
ourselves and I have to say this is
stunning like really really stunning
really stunning I'm so happy to like
welcome her to the family every Spritz
new can new flavor like it feels like
you're birthing a child and this is a
beautiful wonderful child and the um the
campaign that was shot for it features a
we hired a big time model a big time
model are the images out yet they should
be out like today right by the time this
episode goes up everyone will be able to
purchase and everyone will be able to
see the model the photo shoot okay so
our big
model counselor snitch she's having a
big month first she's the amused for a
children's book now she's the like the
face of Spritz Society passion fruit
she's not going to talk to you for a
month after calling her a big
model wait speaking of models she's not
wrong for that speaking of models I
totally forgot to tell you about my
Spritz meet and greet in La I met so
many toasters it was fabulous and I met
a couple interesting toasters with
interesting stories to tell ready
listening these two girls they were so
tall and beautiful I'm like okay models
they're like no we are models like by
trade we are toaster models and they
really came all this way to the meetting
greet and waited line to thank us for
our service of Defending modeling and
how bring light to the plight of models
BR light to the plight of models they
were like you speak to our soul every
time you know people always diminish our
work you know you just stand there and
look pretty and you guys constantly you
know reaffirming the trials and
tribulations of being a model is they
feel very seen so I wanted to share that
with you I love that for us plot twist
like Honestly Hot take the coal miners
could never oh my God the co the coal
miners can never but also the models can
never right honestly models should marry
coal miners because they both have such
strong work ethics in jobs that are
underappreciated and they would probably
they both have plates they both have PL
that need to be brought into the light
and another toaster I met which was so
interesting I already told you this I
wish I didn't tell you I wish I could
have gotten your natural reaction on the
podcast but I think all the toasters
need to know this oh this is so
important you guys he's a celebrity hair
stylist and he works for you know a very
popular podcaster who we have outright
beef with and he's a big toaster so he
listens every day and he has told the
smartless guys about our attempts to
cancel them and hashtag smartless is
over party he said they thought it was
hilarious like they know it's a joke and
they thought it was hilarious and
honestly it was the best piece of news
anyone's ever told me it is so so funny
it's funny cuz like I would feel like
those guys like have no idea who we are
but like if they check their charts like
we're right there they say our big ugly
faces every day right and they know
we're creeping up on them so I'm just
like so it's weird that it shocks me so
much that they like know about our
podcast yeah but of course they do wait
also speaking of our two big faces I was
having a thought recently because our we
had a whole Rebrand photo shoot for our
cover art and that was probably like 30
pounds ago for me and part of me is is
you know mad and wants my current
physique to be reflected in our artwork
but then another part of me is like what
if I gain weight and then I have to look
at this skinny photo every day for the
podcast I think I'd actually prefer to
leave it as is right yeah I mean there's
nothing to talk about now until I'm down
like another 1020 so we can revisit this
maybe in the spring no but I'm saying I
I don't think we need to revisit it I
feel like it's a fair representation of
both of us like it's not it's not like
my heaviest postpartum look but it's and
it's not my like lowest um I like I'm
I'm not obsessed with the photos but I
do not hate them like I feel like that's
how you should feel yeah no I feel like
you should be you should be obsessed
with the photos honestly like it's every
day yeah but imagine like you know it
was like 2019 and I had to look at that
all the time and it was just like and
then people would be like she doesn't
look like that any more and I like what
is more hurtful than that no that like I
I just like hurt my own feelings with
that wait I brought it up to say like I
think we should leave it even though we
weren't even talking about not leaving
it no and we're not the kind of people
that have like a a photo shoot a year
like we do one every five years like
I'll talk to you in 2028 no and we went
so hard on that photo shoot we spent so
much money like it was a fancy ass photo
shoot we leave like we're leaving it and
I don't think we have evolved enough
since that shoot to where like the
concept would be any different than it
was for that shoot like in 5 years who
knows what ideas we'll have for a photo
shoot but like right now I'd say yeah
like pink Blazers sitting on the floor
with a microphone what else are we going
to do champagne and cigars right yeah I
think it's good I look forward to
evolving past it but what would be next
that's the
thing I don't
know it's fun to think about but we have
we've got four years we've got four
years four more years I'm so happy to be
home by the way I was supposed to be on
a flight like now and the thing with LA
is when you fly home you lose your whole
day like I would have lost this whole
day I was supposed to pre-record with
Ben yesterday this is so much better oh
there was a celebrity on my flight Pedro
Pascal I feel like I love flying the New
York La route there's I've seen aiz
anari on a flight I've seen Aon on a
flight and now I can add Pedro Pascal I
was like no way I'm not like super
familiar with him I didn't watch that
show I watched narcos but I wasn't like
100 I'm like I know was
him he gets his eyes squeezed out by the
mountain oh my God you're right I forgot
wait we don't talk about him enough when
we talk about the cast of Game of
Thrones but the commenters always remind
us that he is you know one of the more
successful people who came out of Game
of Thrones but I feel like like Peter
Dinklage like we know him before Game of
Thrones and we know him after so I don't
think of him as like just Game of
Thrones yeah no you're right but wait I
totally forgot but he also had like a
brief stint he wasn't he wasn't a main
character also I feel like a lot of the
main characters you know they were the
younger they were the kids of powerful
people like the Stark kids and the
Lannisters and so they didn't have much
of a career beforehand cuz they're 12 um
so it's like different to compare it to
like the actors who were like 4050 yeah
yeah he was from Dorne right yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh speaking of Game of Thrones
our Halloween episode is coming up yep
we were pring PR mhm I'm I'm so excited
it's going to be so excited too I think
it's going to be like like one of our
Hall of Fame like moments it's
like when it's like it just makes too
much sense you know and sometimes we
really have to like grassp straws like
even though this is such a fun one like
Ryan and shpe was like out of control I
would say that wasn't like our our best
one no but there's never been a bad one
but it's like when you're comparing it
to the Grits what do you think is our
greatest maybe the Jonas Brothers just
because snitch yeah oh no wait William
and Harry is so great
yes wait Jackie we need snitch and I
have a a role for her yeah of course me
too okay I wonder if it's the same it
is is it okay we'll talk
offline yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay
um William and Harry was the best one
per hands down I do have a special place
in my heart for the Jonas Brothers like
Margo being Kevin while having strep
throat and wanting to kill us like the
guitar Paul Nassif like also I feel feel
like it's not even about what we do in
the episode it's about like we'll shoot
like a video right before and like that
Jonas brother's video is [__]
hysterical of us fighting for the front
and maro's like miserable in the back
and then the William and Harry and Queen
video like that's the best video we've
ever done yeah we had sherpe we had the
Kardashians we had Game of Thrones Game
of Thrones yeah that was I feel like
we're missing one we've been doing this
for like the breath no no no so the
breath we were each other yeah great but
a great episode that cured our
relationship indefinitely yeah we will
never do that again I wouldn't recommend
doing that with friends like you get to
know what someone really thinks of you
when they pretend to be you it's [__]
hurtful then we were Kardashians which
was a hit Y snitch as snitch Jenner so
good then we were Jonas
Brothers then we Ryan and Sharpe William
and Harry then Ryan and Ryan and shpe
then Game of Thrones five okay and then
this year is pretty good too yeah I
think this year we'll be top three
yeah we have to also um are you gonna
come here I don't think so I don't it
will be our first Halloween remote but I
actually think that might be better I
agree I agree okay so not to like keep
being talking about something that you
guys have no idea what we're talking
about but it'll all make sense soon and
then Ben and I are going to Heidi clums
Halloween party and we have an amazing
costume really really Stellar I I I went
you know uh I bought something on
Poshmark wow yeah cuz I needed the
perfect outfit wow yeah um yeah my other
my personal life costume you guys are
going to be quaking I don't think I know
what it is I don't think you do either
but if you thought hard enough you could
piece it together okay it's Chip Jo and
the kids family costume chip and Joe and
the kids no okay wait let me think let
me think let me think if I guess it
right will you tell me yeah okay it's
really not suspenseful I was like kind
of kidding oh but what what are you like
obsessed with it's not about me kids
it's not about me are you going to be
Miss Rachel in the
crew no I'm hanging at my
overalls wait what are the what are your
kids obsessed with like oh my God are
you going to be the camper and the
counselor no but that's really cute
there's no boys in the in the buk oh in
the bunk
um you know wait why am I blinking oh
Micky mcky Micky so I'll be Mini cute
cute cute really cute yeah Mickey Mickey
Mouse so
cute so that's a little Halloween teaser
excited for that we got a lot of fun
stuff coming up we do so I think we
should just get into it into the fast
five stories that you need to know and
the fast five stories that you need to
know are brought to you by Loft I've
become obsessed with Loft not enough
people talk about Loft for fall fashion
I just got a sick kind of quilted green
jacket and they're introducing Loft
cashmere we're adding a little bit more
Lux to our line over at over at Loft
this is a soft launch if you will
they're offering 100% Kashmere sweaters
in a range of Silhouettes and colors but
they're also offering matching H hats
sets scarves and socks so loft is back
and better than ever with a fall
collection of fun feminine fashion Loft
has orchestrated a modern mix of all day
anyday pieces that offer endless
versatility
we're talking about plays on proportion
soft touchable textures exciting new
ways to layer with ideas on how to e
effortlessly put together and pull off
the latest have to have styles this fall
collection is definitely one to
celebrate and includes everything you
need to build stylish feel-good outfits
tip to toe um so let's start showing up
for ourselves and each other by wearing
what we love loft is just so underrated
I feel like for many years they've
really just been turning out Lukes and
now everyone's taking notice whether you
need cute outfits for uh work for girls
night out for cozy Vibes their cashmere
is everything loft is the place to go
and not enough people are talking about
it that's why we're working with them so
as a thanks for listening from now
through January 1st 2024 use code toast
loft.com to receive $25 off your full
price purchase exclusion Supply see
podcast description for terms that's Cod
toast loft.com today's episode is also
brought to you by State Farm so you
think Jake from State Farm is it no it's
tury and Jack from State Farm it's Jack
from State Farm it's Jack from State
Farm and the State Farm personal price
plan helps you create a plan that gives
you options so you get an affordable
price and it comes with a lot of
benefits like the coverage you want a
policy that helps cover what's important
to you and an affordable price just for
you because after all life is better
when you can personalize your
experiences so think about it like this
what are your music playlist podcast
feeds and social media Scrolls all have
in common well they're a reflection of
you we all know my social media page
these days is full of you know the girls
on their Manjaro Journeys Jackie is
probably more about about like you know
night feeding and co-s sleeping or
whatever those things are about and
that's what the State Farm personal
price plan has in common it gives you
options to help you personalize your
coverage so you can protect what you
care about most at an affordable price
just for you so you can see more of
yourself in everything that you do and I
just want to say uh the new heights
podcast is also sponsored by State Farm
and Travis was doing his little jingle
and so I'm just going to one up him cuz
his like wasn't good and they tried to
harmonize okay so let's try to harmonize
oh okay three 2 one let good neighbor
State Farm is there okay I don't know
what I did like a good neighbor State
Farm is there call or go to
statefarm.com today to create your State
Farm personal price plan prices do vary
by state options selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary so
just call or go to statefarm.com today
to create your statefarm personal price
plan because life is just better comedy
is better P poetry is better food is
just better when it's personalized and
State Farm understands that so thank you
Jax from State Farm thank you lard from
you're welcome State firm lard from
State
fer our first story Britney Spear is
another bombshell from her Memoir like
the hits start coming and they don't
stop coming I talked about this with
Olivia when we did the podcast together
but I will definitely be reading her
book now like yeah there's a lot of
compelling things coming out and she's
recalling sobbing during her
excruciating at home abortion with
Justin Timberlake so Britney aborted her
and Justin's baby at home without
telling her family that she had been
pregnant the stronger singer shares in
her forthcoming Memoir that she and
Justin agreed not to go to a doctor or
Hospital in order to keep their secret
from going public quote it was important
that no one find out about the pregnancy
or the abortion which meant doing
everything at home she wrote in her book
Spears who was about 19 at the time
describes the physical pain of the
medication abortion as
excruciating she terminating a pregnancy
using pills causes quote cramping and
bleeding to empty your uterus according
to Planned Parenthood which compares the
process to an miscarriage she said I
kept crying and sobbing until it was all
over she wrote in her book it took hours
and I don't remember how it ended but I
do 20 years later remember the pain of
it and the fear no it's so
sad
um yeah I agree this book is everywhere
like so many little things and you
really get a picture even just like from
the excerpts that that we're reading of
how probably damaged and broken Britney
is and then you you have a lot of
Sympathy for the person we're seeing now
because that's a person who's been
through extraordinary things yeah and I
feel like when we think of like the
years that
probably hurt her the most you think of
like the
conserv right the conservatory
conservatorship Conservatory
conservatory and um that period of time
and of course you like think about the
fact that she was a child star and there
are things that come along with that but
like I just feel like all of this is so
compounded over the years but by the
time you know she finishes telling her
story it's like how could anyone be okay
yeah it's really really sad and I saw
she has beat H Prince Harry for most
books sold I think he had sold like
three and a half million and I read
somewhere and don't quote me on this
because it was a tweet but that she's
already sold 9 million books I didn't
see anything like that if it's not even
out yet no I know so I don't know if
that's true and I I think a lot of um
there's a lot of stuff coming out about
this book for press because she can't
really do interviews so I think a lot of
stuff is just being thrown to create
hype which is a smart PR mean it's
worked for me it is it is I said months
ago I wasn't going to read it but now
I'm certainly going to read it are you
going to read it yeah yeah I also um I
can't help a think about Justin
Timberlake oh yeah he's having a bad
month week year you know he's trying to
hide behind in sync and his new song and
it's a it's a decent move cuz they're so
beloved he can use some of that Goodwill
but it's not a good look for him yeah
the timing is interesting I because I
felt like he was
relatively nowhere to be seen for a
while and maybe he should have kept that
energy until the hype of the book is
over and then do the insync thing
because now I think the insync thing
will be washed away by this yeah I was
also saying to Olivia like he should
write a book
too yeah he's definitely in his villain
era and I think he'll be there for a
while and everyone can have some sort
of redemption era as well but I do think
it'll be a while yeah well I haven't
seen that much I mean I also don't see a
lot you know I'm not on Tik Tok and I
don't know where these things happen
like the pitchforks come out to play but
I haven't seen that much energy for him
like in this moment have you yeah
especially with the abortion and like
now people are just going back and
rewatching his music video for CRI a
river and Britney's music video for um
every time right where there's a woman
giving birth and I don't think people
really understood what that meant at the
time so now that we're going back we
have content and we know now that we
know we can go back with more
information I I think it's going to get
worse for for sure yeah well our next
Story another trip down memory L memory
Lan because Aaron Foster claims Chad
Michael Murray had an egregious affair
with Sophia Bush while they were dating
wait I saw this and I want to talk about
it and then I also want to talk about
Sophia Bush because you and I haven't
spoken about it and I'm obsessed with
that story cuz you no I was obsessed
with Ashlin and Ally like during the
women's soccer when they were you know
winning and everyone was obsessed with
them that was like when Taylor brought
them out like and then they got married
and everyone was obsessed I was obsessed
I follow them both on Instagram still
yeah I'm shocked well Erin Foster is
getting candid about her relationship
with ex-boyfriend Chad Michael Murray um
Erin who's a OC uh Lum and daughter of
David Foster opened up about her dating
Arin was on the OC yeah she was dating
um
Seth I think she yeah I think she worked
at the that was Olivia wild no who
worked at the bar no I'm telling you oh
no she played Heather oh my God even
okay you're right she played like bull
Chuck's like girlfriend Heather no yes
I'm sorry the Foster sisters are iconic
like Sarah Foster in 90210 not enough
people talk about their acting resumes
because they're Stellar they're Stellar
like they're such good actresses it's
like it's not like oh I saw Aaron Foster
in this it's like oh that was Heather
right no I mean Jen from 90210 Naomi
sister one of the greatest characters in
in cinematic history and that was Sarah
Foster agreed agreed obsessed but like
also their show barely famous like was
so good it was like too smart and funny
for this world because everybody likes
crap yeah everybody likes crap anyways
that's how I felt about Gary janetti's
uh animated the prince like too too
funny and witty for this world like
people couldn't appreciate it and that's
why it was cancelled like Alan Gregory
Alan [__] Gregory yeah no so many
shows like that are the society like too
good yeah too above people's heads they
they like they were too good they had no
choice but to be
cancelled yeah cuz people are dumb we're
seeing that every day right now how dumb
people are I'm in shock over the
dumbness I'm not I'm no I shouldn't be
but like I seriously am at the volume
and volume the volume and the level of
stupidity I'm seeing on the internet
yeah yeah yet so of course like we can't
have shows like barely famous and Allan
Gregory definitely not Alan Gregory
not enough people talk about Jonah
Hill's one season Wonder animated Effect
Show where he plays this like
six-year-old kid who has like the brain
of a 45-year-old and he has two gay dads
and they're in a thruple like it was and
he goes to like middle school with these
moronic kids but he himself is like this
really kind of refined like audite man
yeah and he brings like his sushi in his
briefcase it's the best show and it
happens to be one of the shows I have
like I had bought it on iTunes anytime
I'm on a flight and I like don't have
Wi-Fi and I have the only thing I can
watch is Alan Gregory and it really aged
very well I'm sure it does so funny
anyways let's get to the story KY Erin
opened up about her dating life on the
latest episode of her and her sister
Sarah's podcast the world's first
podcast and alleged that she'd been
jilted by Chad Michael Murray in the
past she said um I was also featured in
this dumo thing with Chad Michael Murray
in it it said and apparently he cheated
on her with Sophia Bush by the way
dumois is not they don't lie I mean that
is what happened Aon was like yeah he
definitely did cheat on me with her in
like a pretty egregious way while we
were living together oh my God they were
living together she said I'm o I'm I've
moved on though I'm over it now she said
I'm just barely over it just barely I
didn't know that they him and Sophia
Bush got married yeah I had no idea that
she dated him either she dated him in
2001 to 2002 so like we were nine no but
that's so foster sisters like they
really have been at the center of pop
culture
forever and so when I saw this story I
didn't know that they had dated but it
made complete sense to me
yeah and I feel like Chad Michael Murray
is another one of those who was really
popular in the early 2000s and things
come out about him now all the time that
are like not good really yeah I feel
like cuz the one Tre Hill girls are
always talking they have a podcast they
do events together um and they're like
naming names you know what do they say
about him well there was like a
showrunner on that show who was very
inappropriate a lot of them have like
really bad experiences from the show and
I don't remember exactly what they said
but they they talk about it all the time
because he and uh Sophia Bush had a very
bad divorce yeah so Sophia Bush like
that's what I want to talk about Sophia
Bush I'm obsessed with this story like
so now people are saying that Ashen
Harris cheated on Ali creger because Ali
creger had like a big party and like a
bunch of her soccer friends were there
and her brother commented on it Kyle
creger which is such a great name Kyle
creger and he was like he wrote
something about like two
timing H yeah but also they have a child
together Ashlin and two and Ashlin took
Mama out of her Instagram bio I saw that
but like did she overhaul the whole bio
you know right right it's POS she did
she did a Rebrand but I don't know I I'm
not a mom so I don't know but like to
put it in once you put it in like that's
something don't take out no unless
you're like then you know
just just doing something completely
different not like being like soccer
player Mama author daughter lover like
and instead you're just like check out
my new short
series okay wait no her mom is mom is
now in
there proud mom to SLO and ocean reti
retired professional athlete two-time
world champion okay yeah so she's
listing her accolades if she like wiped
all that and was instead like you know
Ukrainian flag then I don't think people
would be like so concerned where'd Mama
go okay and Ali says proud mommy
footballer oh wow she's British PSU Alum
and trustee an Adidas football athlete
yeah they're listing their accolades so
I if as long as it's not out of there
it's
not but so she had a party concern and
like it appeared like a lot of the
soccer girls that we know like Megan
Rino like they were with her so I feel
like ash oh and then like the US women
soccer team I'm obsessed with this story
the US Women's Soccer Team put up a
photo because it was just ashlin's
birthday happy birthday to time World
Champ Ashen Harris the
comments because they say she's like a
two-time two-time world champion oh two
timer two timer
indeed like it's a play on
words
yeah I so there's a lot going on in the
women's soccer team Universe yeah
and then by the way so Sophia Bush had
been like friends with the couple if you
go back on Instagram there's a lot of
times Sophia Bush commented on stuff and
was like giving kind of like desperate
energy and now to know like she's with
one of them it's too much
yeah I'm I don't know enough about all
these people like even like what I was
saying to even Sophia Bush like I never
you watched one Tre Hill up until the
point I didn't I don't watch women's
soccer I didn't follow the girls that
like on the team who were together and
so like really this is just an
interesting story to me but I'm not
invested like you are I'm invested
because when the women's soccer team
like were so popular with their big win
at the World Cup or whatever um everyone
was talking about them and then I
realized like so many of them follow me
on Instagram so I followed them all back
and now I'm just like I'm a basically
the goalie you're part of the team
ashleen Harris is the goalie was the
goalie you're the water boy pretty much
yeah no I'm I'm like Nate you're the kit
man yeah I'm the the kit man what do
they call that in the US cuz we don't
call it a kit I think that's a no not
the water boy no it's like the uniform
person I feel like I don't
know makes you think they would give it
like a nice name it would be like you
know linen
manager
yeah sound up in the
comments I love sports literally I
really love sports everything I've been
watching recently like TI back to sports
sports are having such a moment like
between football and taylored and
Beckham beckh and what was the other
thing I just oh I just watched Kelsey
right at home with the furies like all
different types of sports are getting
their moment for everyone I know Sports
have been popular always but like with a
specific group but now they're they're
popular yeah finally sports are popular
no when I tell you like I'm going to
watch football tonight like oh I'm make
you a chil when I tell you last night I
was scrolling on TV for something to
watch waiting for Southern Charm to come
on and I was looking for a football game
and it was not
on no thir so I I felt like football was
on every night but it's not and actually
I have some notes for like the
programming of the football Society but
it's Friday night Sunday night and
Monday night and Sunday day and Monday
night but like then there's a few games
Friday and Monday and then all of them
are on at the same time on Sunday like
space it out spread it out I would watch
it every night if I really would yeah
that way the husbands don't have to be
with like their four screens
yeah all day Sunday
yeah free idea just a
note are you ready for our next SP story
speaking of sports adjacent oh yeah
Taylor Swift Selena Gomez and Friends
get a bite to eat in La during uh
Connecticut pandemonium over Travis
Kelce dining rumors so that's a sep
story yeah there was this fake news that
they were in Connecticut when they were
not instead Selena Taylor were in La um
grab some sushi in West Hollywood with
Zoe Kravitz and Kelly Sperry what is the
name of this sushi place Sushi park
because like the photos that's where we
saw it's the same restaurant where we
saw Kylie and Jordan Woods reunite for
the first time it appears to be in like
a mall it's like a strip mall yeah it
looks like not a fancy place and every
a-lister goes in the sushi must be
amazing yeah you should have gone well
you don't even love sushi Ben should
have gone Ben should have gone what's it
called again w
uh Sushi Park Sushi Park okay it doesn't
even sound
fancy
um also Blake Lively was there yeah
sorry there was just a confusing worded
sentence so okay so Blake Lively Zoe
Kravitz Kelly Taylor and Selena yes so
it's basically like Taylor's crew and
Selena
joined Selena's not like Selena's not
like part of the larger group no she's
just like a bigger star who Taylor knows
and is really really close she's just
like like Taylor's like Camp friend yeah
but like Kelly and Blake definitely know
each other Zoe and Blake definitely know
like they're a crew in and of themselves
got it so Selena got the invite to hang
out with the home friends yeah yeah no
it's literally Camp friend got it okay
cute especially because I think Selena
permanently resides in
LA and Blake is they live in like
Toronto right no they live Upstate in
New York yeah they live upstairs I don't
know why I know that but I do know that
why did I think they lived in Canada
because he's Canadian Van City no they
live Ina Canada like I'm telling you why
do you think they live Upstate and where
um I actually know the name of the town
but I'll just are you're not going to
say it no cuz I don't know how I know it
so I'm not going to say it where Blake
Lively Ryan Reynolds live I'm going to
get like flagged literally yeah they
live um they live in new New
York okay so yeah Taylor I Feel where
would you say Taylor
lives she's kind of a citizen of the
world I don't know
I like not Nashville no not Nashville I
would say either New York or La I think
we just know when she's in New York
because that's the nature of New York
where she has a compound in La we've
never seen her leaving her house in La
cuz you here's a good point of reference
like during Co she quarantined in La so
that's her house that like of all the
houses she like had to co up at like
that was the best one that's her house
you think that's the best one it's
probably the most private one like for
her it's definitely the most private one
cuz that's LA but if you have homes in
all these places why would you choose to
play La taxes if you can do Tennessee no
income tax no that's and she is a
businesswoman let's let's me not forget
I'm maybe her permanent residence is in
Tennessee and she just like makes her to
spend 180 days there well I know that
she spent her reputation you know Off
the Grid time mostly in Nashville
yeah but I just feel like wherever you
chose to go during Co like that's your
primary home yeah well people just makes
me sad you know where is her home you
know that's she's so rich and so famous
and it looks so fabulous but you know
she's kind of untethered yeah but people
did spend Co at their second homes if
they had one also where does Andrea
Swift live
you're asking the wrong person I
actually don't know that not to be a
freak I feel like she would choose her
primary residence close to her mom also
we haven't seen her mom in a long
time she's been hanging out with
Travis's mom yeah but her mom goes to
the shows and there's been no shows yes
did you hear that uh on the toast
yesterday Heather McDonald really
believes that this is like the end all
Beall for she thinks that they're going
to get married and like be very
traditional get married and have kids I
hope that that's true I've said from the
beginning like I don't think that's the
case whatsoever but I feel like after
watching
Beckham I see a path forward they are
that's interesting they are Becca yes
the biggest star musically and the and
what the biggest star athletically and
like the media pandemonium we weren't
really like you know conscious for it
and it also was in another country but
the insane Paparazzi the insane stories
every single day can't escape it it's
you're right it they're parallel stories
yeah so after seeing that it definitely
made me think like oh this happens and
it could be something real and I hope
that it is because it's just been fun
for the whole family and by the way if
we ever got like a dinner with Travis
Taylor Posh and Beckham I would die do
you think I feel like it's not out of
the realm of
possibility I feel like it is really
yeah but but you and Heather were
talking about like pop culture
predictions like you know calling them
like I'm always wrong I feel like yeah
no but but that's the part of this job
like you say 55 things they're all wrong
except for one and then you get lauded
as some sort of Genius because you got
one right yeah I feel like I think not
enough people talk about that like I
pretty much accurately predicted the
name of Britt's Memoir I was going to
say not a girl not yet a woman and she
chose another lyric from the same exact
song I'm just trying to find the woman
in me
like you don't think so
no no but but like not enough people
talk about how he predicted Selen a song
Single yeah wait how did I say it went
like I am like so like we thought it was
going to be called I am single like I am
the single sh but we were right about it
being a single about being single sorry
like we're we're claiming that wait what
what how did I say it went what was the
caption of that like it was like I am
single is what she said so we thought it
was going to be a single called I am
no I remember I'm trying to remember the
song lyrics that I wrote I am free I am
no that was the chorus we eventually got
to but the original song I'm too danc oh
I'm too good I'm too good at being alone
yeah I'm too get a I don't remember how
I sang it to dance with your heart
whatever I need to go back like that was
I need to just actually write that song
you do she left it on the table for I
like being alone too much to dance with
your heart I like being alone too much
to dance with your heart obsessed that
was honestly better than that song
Selena
released yeah I'll be single soon I
like cringe it wasn't great it wasn't
great no no are you ready for our next
story is it the next story that's
brought to you by Lael TI this episode
of the toast is brought to you by the
new L'Oreal Paris bright revealed dark
spot serum and broadspectrum SPF 50
daily lotion you have dark spots game
over I just spent so much time in the
sun in La like I'm so conscious of dark
spots I've had them my whole life and I
didn't realize it was something that you
could actually proactively do something
about and no more dark spots thanks to
L'Oreal so if you've been spending a lot
of time in the sun ever since summer
ended playing pickle ball and you've
noticed more sunspots like I have check
out the L'Oreal bright reveal so there's
fabulous ingredients in this product
like niacinamide amino sulfonic ferulic
acid the dark spot Serum is fabulous
it'll visibly Fade All types of dark
spots up to 40% so that's post acne
marks age spots sun spots in a clitical
study over TW 12 weeks experts expert
grading of dark spots age and sunspots
and post acne marks so after 12 weeks
you can see up to 40% less visible post
acne marks 43% less visible dark spots
and 49% more even tone in one week you
can start fading your stubborn dark
spots L'Oreal is one of my favorite
Beauty Brands I just think everything
they make is fabulous and also the SP F
uh 50 daily UV lotion wearing sunlock
under your makeup is a non-negotiable
the older we get I Feel Like We we
forgot in the beginning and we're not
forgetting anymore so the bright reveal
SPF 50 daily UV lotion is fabulous and
it can visibly reduce the appearance of
dark spots and resist sunu signs of
damaging so discover the new bright
revealed dark spot Duo visit Target
online and in store to buy yours today
that's Target online and in store to buy
the duo today today's episode is also
brought to you by Nine West so 9 West is
one of the world's most recognized
Brands they Define Timeless feminine
style and they translate key trends into
wearable attainable Styles I feel like 9
West is one of those brands that we have
known forever and they have been good
and solid and with us for years and you
know it's time to up your shoe game 9
West makes shopping Trends easier with
their need it now edit also known as the
nine edit that highlights key trends
such as western style boots loafers and
more so for the perfect going out Shoe
Shop their F collection the F stands for
Fierce and feminine heels with a 3.8 in
stiletto they are so comfortable and
they have collections of Footwear
obviously that's what we know but they
also offer fabulous apparel fabulous
accessories it's really just a fun brand
I think uh every year shoe Trends it's
really hard to keep up so just go to 9
West and they got what you need they're
doing all the work for you they have
great edits on their website their shoes
are really comfortable they're really
wellmade they're really fabulous and you
can be bound for greatness as well they
are energizing a new 9 West with
fashional on brand and culturally
shoes that Embrace Sisterhood and
Inspire women everywhere to Take On The
World in style so visit 9 West and use
code toast at checkout their website is
ninewest.com and using Code toast at
checkout you will get 15% off your first
purchase that's n i NE west.com use code
toast for 15% off your first order thank
you la you're welcome our next story is
pretty interesting Vanity Fair is
prepping a deeply reported probe into
Bravo's relationship with Housewives
Stars so Vanity Fair is preparing to
publish a deeply reported probe into the
complicated relationships between Bravo
and its Stars page six has learned
sources say a reporter for the famed
magazine has been interviewing cast
members and other sources around the
Real Housewives franchise for some six
months and that the piece is slated to
appear in the coming weeks we're told
the article is expected to delve into
the highly demanding work lives of the
real housewife stars and what they trade
in terms of their privacy their image
and even their mental health and
relationship with alcohol in order to
keep their much coveted often highly
paid roles the journalist is really
going deep into what the women go
through on what's expected of them as
members of the cast and members of the
Bravo family said an Insider I think
it's going to explain to a lot of fans
that don't really see or understand
about how it really works we hear that
given vanity Fair's reputation for
rigorous wide- ranging reporting there
have been some nerves jangling at
Bravo's HQ over the piece but Network
insiders say execs are well used to the
spotlight being pointed at the
high-profile media firm and that
nobody's sweating it sources say say
that during their interview stars have
been invited to reflect on what they
have given up to appear on the show
whether it's been worth it and how much
control in retrospect they feel that
they really had meanwhile page six
here's the piece also looks into Bravo's
various protocols and guidelines for
addressing the well-beings of its stars
and to what they to what degree they are
affected yeah I feel like there's
probably a lot for this journalist to
get into I think there will be some
crazy things that come out I do not
think it will affect the brand at all
but this is like a recent trend
and Nene and Brandon Glenville a lot of
people have been very outspoken about um
the Network's lack of care when it comes
to handling their Stars I also think a
lot of what you just read is kind of the
nature of the business not so much
Bravo's fault like yeah a lot of these
women do give their husbands do give up
their jobs to do this full-time and then
they end up getting fired the next
season and that's not necessarily
Bravo's fault that's the nature of
reality TV but I'm sure Bravo is
responsible and and I'm sure there's a
lot lot of things that will come out in
this article that are done at the hands
of Bravo yeah I think that it's a gamble
that you take when you go on any reality
TV show like it could absolutely make
your career and all of that risk could
be worth it and you'll be in front of an
audience like even a Bethany you know
and I would say that was all worth it
but all there on the flip side like you
might be one season wonder and in that
one season like you you've embarrassed
your family your husband loses his job
like you lose your house like it's a
risk I was actually when I was just
reading Molly May's book she was an
influencer before she went on love
Island and she was like I knew that
going on the show like I was risking
like embarrassing myself and not never
coming back from that but the reward
from it is also incredibly great if it
goes well and for her obviously it did
so there's pros and cons I kind of just
feel like this article could be written
towards whatever any network yes but
also towards whatever end they want it
to be it could also you could write a
whole article about what all these women
have gained from the show and like a
sense there could be a flattering
article about the independence of some
of these women the businesses that
they've built but yes of course it could
also be about the trolls and the
terrible things but it really is a
choice that every reality star and also
housewife has to make it's like is all
of the potential success worth the
damage to your reputation to your mental
health if it doesn't go well and also
every season is different like you could
have a great season and then you could
experience all of those things and you
know like Erica Jane yep yep yep yep yep
I also would be really curious to know
um because for my POV this is very much
like a Housewives thing when I think of
other Bravo shows like summer house and
vener pump rules like I don't think of
it as toxically as Housewives do you
know what I mean yeah but I would also
argue because maybe some of them aren't
as popular yeah yeah yeah um but this is
just like a a general theme that we've
seen we spoke about it with that guy
from Love is Blind about how you know
reality TV is just very unregulated
there's no Union there's no protection
for the stars and yes a lot of them come
out and Bethany $150 million businesses
like and some of them aren't as big as
that but they make a lot of money but
then there are always the untold stories
of that guy Nick from Love is Blind
who's on the verge of being homeless
yeah it's like depending on who they
choose to interview you could write any
story you could well now Bethany sings a
different tune but if you interviewed
Melissa Gorga I would say is a good
example of like I of the show being
great for her or are we interviewing
Lynn
from the OC oh oh oh oh yeah yeah who do
you think that they're going to talk to
I think they'll talk to Bethany and N I
think they'll talk to a lot of former
Stars I don't know if any current stars
like are allowed to engage with this or
even would no they would not Bravo is
the hand that feeds them so if you're
currently but they they might talk and
say positive things oh oh oh oh oh oh
yeah people feel positively about it
yeah yeah yeah but it's just this catch
22 of reality TV right like we like to
watch crazy people doing crazy things
but those things and those it has
consequences like oh my God I would
never do a reality show like really
never yeah it's just not worth it no for
me like I would look at the the risks
and the rewards and I would say no thank
you yeah but for other people
like they would feel the opposite and
there are rewards and it pays off a lot
of the time yeah but you have to be
prepared for if it doesn't yes and
that's why that those are like the
hardest stories when you know one season
wonders who really thought that this was
going to change their life like buy
bigger houses and their husbands quit
their jobs like that's irresponsible
yeah well there's also there are people
who like are actively irresponsible but
then there are people who like you know
they do the show and it just doesn't pan
out the way like they didn't even make
bad choices it's just like they don't
get a second season or you know the the
husband's company does doesn't like him
being on the show fired and it's like I
didn't even do anything right like the
association a lot of times their kids
are asked to leave the schools yeah I
feel like this article won't be like
that shocking for maybe like you or I
are listeners of our show who are like
so deep into like you know following so
many houses and like knowing their
personal stories but maybe for like a
more passive casual viewer it will be
shocking shocking that's a good point so
TBD on that everybody thinks that they
know us
are you ready for our fifth and final
story I really am sag Afra is telling
its members to not dress up as
characters uh from struck companies for
Halloween and Mandy Moore is not [__]
having it did you see what she posted on
Instagram no what did she say so this
this thing went viral like because uh I
think a lot of people would dress up as
Barbie and Ken I think that's what
inspired it and sag was like just a
reminder it's considered crossing the
picket line to dress up for Halloween as
a character from a a sag film and
mandore posted it and was like are you
[__] serious like can we get back to
the table a lot of people have
sacrificed a lot of things a lot of
people are not working and this is what
you're reminding us about like get back
to work we just lost the the exec just
walked away we're back at square one is
this really what we should be focusing
on right now no they're out of control
insane and you know what I was just when
I was in LA I was getting my makeup done
and she was telling me how this how the
strike has really been really hard for
her because she does a lot of um
celebrities not on
on set but to go to premieres and
promotional events and interviews and so
that's just like another layer of people
who are not protected by sag severely
impacted by the um strike and it's just
it's a long time now and I I agree with
Mandy more like seriously this is a
waste of your time yeah like that's not
moving the needle on the
discussions sag after release guidelines
for members looking to celebrate Hall
Halloween this year while also staying
in solidarity with the strike that means
union members can hang up their a
Oppenheimer pork pie hats and put away
their Barbie pink they said choose
costumes inspired by generalized
characters and figures ghost zombie
spider Etc everyone showing up to kigos
Halloween party as Spider Stop The Guild
also suggests actors quote don't post
photos of costumes inspired by struck
content to social media as to not give
the studios any additional publicity a
sag Abra fights for a better contract
with amtp striking out s are prohibited
from doing press for struck shows and
films the post encourages members to
dress up as characters from non- struck
content like an animated TV show oh I'm
within the guidelines oh am I I'm not
iard is not no okay I is so so if you
dress up as a struck character whatever
struck means I'm just going to go with
it um are you a scab anyone dressed up
as Barbie the Sears scab no because
we're you're not in the Union
so all this time when people's calling a
scab for be for like asking questions I
wasn't a scab actually I don't know do
you have to be in the union to be a scab
yeah yeah yeah exactly because the PE no
no no you don't have to be because
remember we were saying the people who
might like take a job yes yes yes so
anyone who dresses up as Barbie this
year is a scab I'm just putting that out
there wow
wow wow also our costumes this year are
sad compliant they are we are sad
compliant this is just like in my
opinion such a waste of energy and and
promotion like and you know I was
supposed to meet friend dresser this
week because at this panel I did which
was a variety event for anti-Semitism
she was a kyot speaker and because of
all the SAG drama she's you know back
negotiating she was unable to attend so
I I hope this isn't what she was working
on like come on no people need to work
no this is I just like Miss the days
when the SAG drama was like the biggest
drama you know that's why I chose this
story like I miss sag I agree talking
about sagra and they love saying it too
and you say it weird sagra yeah you
can't say without adding an S after the
F no watch me
sagra sounds wrong
sagra that's that not only does that
sound wrong it is wrong I just miss it
bring me back yeah I agree to the simple
times the simple times when all we were
arguing about was sag Afra Afra
um well thank
youen Saga
Stena I love that take me back please
take me back that's our show that's our
week
yeah hope everybody had a good week has
some nice enjoyable plans for the
weekend take some time for yourself
recharge renew restore
rebirth sag Afra sag Afra strong you
guys thank you thank you guys so much
for listening to the to Mill Morning
Show where we deliver the fast stories
that you need to every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please to subscribe and
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as podcast anywhere podcast
Spotify podcast beautiful standing and
wickedly talented we are hope you guys
have an amazing day don't forget to get
your copy of the camper and the
counselor don't forget to get your copy
it's hard to find a copy these days but
they do exist I have um I've been
updating my Instagram with places that
you can get copies you can get it on
Amazon Barnes & Noble books a million
shout out to books a million I don't
think they ever were out of stock I
think they go by bam bam yeah I think
they rebranded bam [__] bullet rips
off part of your head bam the camper and
the counselor rips off part of your head
which the camper and the counselor would
never do also people are loving the
camper and the counil I've gotten so
many messages about how like they're
addicted they there's something
addictive about the book my theory it's
the colors is it's the animation because
it looks like you know a Disney show
just like in a book format so it's like
okay not all kids want to choose to read
a book over watching TV but it kind of
like fuses both yep yep yep yep that's
my theory as to why the kids love
it Theory theor I had a lot of theories
today I'm like the Pythagorean theorem
you're like a theorist I I mean I am a
theorist yes and that's what we do on
the show generally speaking as we
theorize but I feel like today I had a
lot of theories for Friday thank you
guys love you bye love you
bye